a devastating new report laying out the
Damage Done to our children by covered
school shutdowns and the Biden
Administration is blaming Donald Trump
for it recent scores on a key National
test revealing the worst drop in math
and reading scores in decades for fourth
grade students math scores uh dropping
seven points marking a first ever
decline while reading scores slipped
Five Points Republican Senator Ron
Johnson calling out the teachers unions
for failing our kids what's so tragic
about how we harmed our children during
our responses it wasn't driven by the
science uh the school shutdowns in our
CDC response to uh how we're going to
handle children it was largely driven by
the teachers unions and get this instead
of punishing the teachers unions who
pushed lockdowns the White House is
blaming Trump for the student learning
loss it shows you how mismanaged uh the
pandemic was and how the impact of that
mismanagement had on the on kids
progress and academic well-being and so
again our priority remains to make sure
States and schools and districts are
using these funds that 130 billion
billion dollars we must repair the
damage that was done by the last
Administration the mismanagement that
was done by the Matt lastman
Administration
you know the the truth is Dana that this
is the first time in in history that
some of the ninth grade nine-year-olds
and fourth graders have suffered the
enormous deficit in math but in English
as well so the White House is blaming
Trump they're not blaming the unions
when it was the unions who kept saying
we can't go we can't go back to teach
it's dangerous when it was only
dangerous for them the children there
was no danger to them and they got all
this money that they haven't even spent
okay so first on the unions and then
I've got a broader answer on do you
remember when Rochelle valensky the head
of the CDC came out and said I think
schools should reopen we've got to get
kids back in school and the White House
put out a statement said she was
speaking in her personal capacity when
the CDC sign was right behind her yeah
and then what did we find out oh there
were the emails between CDC and the
teachers union saying when the teachers
union wanted the school to be kept shut
down that's exactly what happened we
have the proof in black and white now to
the White House if your answer to this
problem when you wake up in the morning
you see this in the papers if your
immediate reaction is let's blame Donald
Trump instead of we're on top of it we
are as alarmed as American parents this
is what we're going to do president
Trump's calling a cabinet meeting it's
going to be 8 A.M he wants every cabinet
secretary to come with three possible
solutions for how we're going to spend
96 of the money that the American
taxpayer gave to deal with this covet
issues with the schools and hasn't been
spent yet and we're going to call upon
the American people to to figure out a
way to everyone agree to take on a child
and you tutor them and we're going to
make a massive effort to get this done
and this is important if your answer is
not we are alarmed and going to do
something about these children who will
never ever catch up if your answer is to
blame Donald Trump you're definitely in
the wrong business Ryan the Department
of Education the head to Miguel Cardona
said that they're stuck with having to
repair the Damage Done by Trump and the
amount of money by the way was 122
billion in the American Rescue plan 87
percent of which is unspent so Cardona
as opposed to saying we're going to fix
this the Department of Education is
blaming Trump too right I don't think
anybody bought one thing uh the
secretary's probably talking about
policy I'm not sure the press secretary
is even commenting is even speaking for
the for the Biden White House she seemed
to just be Wicked it blame Donald Trump
uh which is an organized well it just it
just seems so clueless and out of touch
like you said solve the problem and then
worry about it later uh if an interview
comes up and say why was this problem so
bad you could say okay this is where I
thought he doesn't give interviews Black
and Hispanic kids were twice as high for
these white students to be remote and
twice as likely to have the uh no live
access to a teacher so they were hurt
even worse you know what killed it uh
Luke Combs sung about it saying about it
six feet apart if they they made this up
and played it off from 1918 the
so-called medical experts and said these
kids got to be six feet apart because of
that they can't get kids in the
classroom because of that they didn't go
back to school and then what found out
it was even based on science that's why
everything was shut down this is what I
would do Huntington Learning Center all
these Learning Centers these annexes
that people pay extra you get their kids
extra help I would get some of that
money get in Private Industry the way
the defense department is helped by
Private Industry to start supplementing
school education because the teachers
already strung out and overworked unless
they want to earn extra money you know
there was talk that that some of the
students might make up the loss of
teaching Time by going to summer school
and they said even those kids didn't
benefit and when you look at this you
know and on a global scale I remember
talking about this Chinese kids are in
school the European kids are in school
it's just the American kids and we
weren't so high on the Spectrum to begin
with and we're falling back in terms of
International Learning how is this
generation going to compete I think well
this I think this system is doomed yeah
uh if I can't blame every I can't blame
it the other side because I didn't think
we knew what we were we were supposed to
do when this was happening but now we do
know what to do and the one thing that
has to be done is parents have to take a
more active serious role in the
education because they because covet did
help them see what was going on with
those Zoom classes and saw what their
kids were being taught meanwhile we know
that the teachers unions are hopelessly
corrupt systemically racist so you got
to go start going to the school board
meetings you have to start speaking up
it's easy for me to say I don't have
kids but you need to have a tea party
style movement uh uh because if you
organize just like the radicals who
organize against you you can you will no
longer be called domestic terrorists in
fact you'll probably have people joining
your movement if I were a parent of a
young brat I'd be looking at private
schools I'd be pushing for states to
fund the students as opposed to the
system like Arizona did and I would be
organized it's time for parents to
become a radical parent by the way
there's a party for that the Republican
party is the party the parents the sadly
the Democratic party is the party of the
teachers union people protecting their
asses they don't you know they don't
want competition you know Jessica the
charter schools the Catholic schools a
lot of the religious schools were were
open while the public schools were were
not open you know the public schools
that were promoting the racist policies
that you know the gender identity stuff
I if you had a child would you send your
child to a public school or would you
use that money to send your child to a
school that you uh believe can better
teach your child it just so happens I do
have a child
um not going to school yet but this is
something that you think about with you
um don't say that to me at all
um I'll consider all of my options but
private school is a tremendous privilege
especially in a lot of these locations
the school that I went to is now 55 000
a year
um so you have to earn a hundred and ten
thousand dollars in New York City to be
able to send your kids there that's not
a viable alternative to this charter
schools and people being able to use
their money for whatever form of
Education they want is something that a
lot of liberal parents are interested
and have been growing increasingly
obviously during the pandemic but to
your point that you made in the a block
about I want to hear from Republicans
what the agenda is you know Glenn
youngkin has the playbook for how to
effectively maximize what happened with
school shutdowns and he did not talk
about CRT he did not talk about grooming
he talked about parents being able to
make decisions for their children and
keeping kids in classrooms without masks
he did not run around talking about
racist teachers he said I want to make
sure that your children are educated
first and foremost and it was a huge
issue in New Jersey as well there were
focus group after focus group of
democratic voters who were turning
against Phil Murphy because their kids
weren't in school so that's the
conversation that both sides need to be
having here and parents are not
necessarily concerned with the ancillary
stuff I get it there might be someone
who's motivated to go out and vote
because they're concerned about CRT but
the bulk of them just want to know that
they're going to a classroom that
they're socializing that they're
learning from someone who's well trained
but the reason but the reason why the
all these school boards switch is
because of the curriculum yeah look at
Florida all these people started running
for school board because they hated the
curriculum they hated the the pick your
gender it's in second grade and they
hated this year America's sucks until
further notice
it's just not the number one thing that
parents are thinking about you're a
parent you wanted your child in the seat
at school with advanced math available
with advanced math available without the
child being asked what sex they want to
be today yes yeah hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else